elles aient Karim on est en janvier 2019
Théo à 7 mois il se réveille et il est
pas bien c'est ça oui
ça a commencé le 15
juin où il était pas bien il vomissait
il mangeait rien il faisait que dormir
il se réveille en pleurant enfin
vraiment pas comme d'habitude donc on a
été une première fois aux urgences où là
cette fois on n'a pas on n'a pas attendu
du tout on a vu en interne qui nous a
dit que ben il venait d'avoir une dent
donc c'était probablement ça ou qui
pouvait quelque chose et donc on est
rentré le soir même quand toi tu es
rentré il a eu du sang dans les selles
donc là on s'est dit bah c'est très
grave et on est retourné aux urgences là
donc aux urgences pédiatriques de vers
chez nous faut savoir que service et on
a attendu cinq heures
pour un bébé de 7 mois qui avait du sang
dans les selles
vous attendez donc 5 heures certains
patients repartent aussi tellement ils
n'en peuvent plus attendre oui les
passions partir petit à petit vous
sentez que le personnel est pressé
forcément
il faut attendre il faut attendre il
faut attendre votre tour dans un couloir
forcément avec le petit les premières
heures on était dans une salle d'attente
et en fait au bout d'un moment on a été
emmené dans un couloir et le petit il
était dans quel état il était toujours
pareil il voulait rien manger il
pleurait il dormait il pleurait alors on
va vous allez nous raconter l'histoire
qui est dramatique la question de tout
le monde se pose et quand la crise de
l'hôpital pousse-t-elle les soignants à
choisir il y a délaisser certains
passions c'est la question qu'on se pose
regardez le témoignage d'une femme dont
le mari est mort après 5 heures
d'attente ils sont prises en charge
regardez on regardait la télé la veille
il avait été passée une prise de sang
notre médecin traitant qui a téléphoné
en me disant j'ai reçu votre prise ça
serait bien quand même d'aller à
l'hôpital il m'a dit je suis désolé mais
faut passer par les urgences Miguel
souffrait d'insuffisance cardiaque pour
éviter l'attente son médecin traitant
lui fait une lettre pour permettre une
prise en charge rapide malgré ce
courrier le retraité est mis sur un
brancard et ne sera jamais examiné par
un médecin l'hôpital reconnecte
clairement un problème de prise en
charge pas de surveillance possible dans
la salle de tri vu le flux et le manque
de personnel une enquête pour rechercher
les causes de la mort de Miguel a été
ouverte par le commissariat de Pau
vous êtes infirmière en plus
vous êtes vous attendez 5 heures que
vous dites interne quand qui voit Théo
en premier en fait c'est le même terme
qu'il a vu le midi et le soir même il
était toujours là épuisé forcément
il voit rien de particulier ils lui font
juste une prise de sang on a attendu les
résultats de la prise de temps on nous
dit de rentrer chez nous on nous donne
des prescriptions pour le réhydrater en
fait j'y pense à une gastro d'accord
donc vous rentrez chez vous vous voyez
que la santé de Théo empire qu'est-ce
qui se passe à ce moment-là
[Musique]
après en fait déjà le mercredi donc
c'est un mardi et donc on rentre des
urgences c'est à peu près deux heures
deux heures et demi du matin elles
travaillaient de se lever à sa carrière
et demi pour aller à son boulot
d'infirmière moi j'ai prévenu ma
patronne comme quoi j'allais pas
travailler pour garder mon fils donc je
suis resté à la maison avec lui il
mangeait pas il buvait pas il vomissait
il dormait je suis descendu à la
pharmacie avec lui pour chercher dans ce
que nous avait prescrit il en voulait
pas parce qu'il y a rien qui passait
donc on lui donnait des petites doses
d'eau tout ça on essaie enfin j'essayais
de régulièrement toutes les heures
toutes les deux heures tout ça d'aller
le réveiller lui donner un petit peu à
manger à boire ça ressortait tout
automatiquement et puis non puis il
était pas bien il était il avait jamais
été malade jusqu'à maintenant enfin
jusqu'à cette date là
et puis on voyait qu'il était pas du
tout bien quoi donc là vous étiez tout
pas il rigolait jamais enfin je dis rien
quoi il dormait et c'est tout il
attendait essayer de retourner aux
urgences on est parti on est aux
urgences
c'est une gastro on a fait confiance aux
médecins et on s'est dit bah une gastro
sans ça passe en ou deux jours c'est pas
grave quoi et en fait la Nuit d'Après
quand moi je me suis levée pour aller
travailler je l'ai entendu pleurer et là
il allait pas bien du tout il avait eu
il était dans les selles et il était
tout tremblant et en fait on a appelé le
SAMU en même temps mais il est décédé
dans mes bras
donc on a essayé de le réanimer
par terre sur la route en attendant de
SAMU parce que on habite à la campagne
le GPS à la campagne le temps qu'il
arrive le samedi on s'est mis au bord
d'une grande route et c'était 6h du
matin et on essayait de réanimer notre
bébé 7 mois par terre dans la rue du
coup parce que bah voilà et du coup bah
après les pompiers sont arrivés et que
ça met aussi on avait l'impression on a
toujours l'impression que c'est très
long je pense pas que c'était très long
mais voilà et du coup nous on prend en
charge et là ça a été on a attendu en
fait on attendait on attendait et
jusqu'au moment où une infirmière et
Mohamed saint est venu du SAMU et nous a
dit qu'ils ont essayé qu'ils avaient un
peu faire
c'est rarement voilà forcément et on
sait de quoi il est décédé après ou pas
sur le moment donc on savait pas nous
sur et du coup il y a une autopsie
directement qui était demandée par la
justice et en fait il est décédé d'une
invasion c'est les intestins en fait qui
rétractent sur même ça fait une
occlusion donc il est décédé tout ça on
aurait pu le voir s'il avait été
la place quand on l'a amené quand il a
eu le perte de sang est-ce que c'était
trop tard ou pas on sait pas mais
peut-être que si jamais
à ce moment-là peut-être qu'ils auraient
voulu et ça aurait pu comme ça même pas
va on y était le mardi et il est décédé
le jeudi matin à 6h du à 6h du matin
mardi peut-être ça aurait été voilà
c'était le mardi soir quoi voilà
peut-être que ça aurait été encore bon
mardi soir
c'est incroyable parce que vous voyez le
manque de moyens qui a des conseillers
en comment ça c'est des conséquences
directes je vous êtes vraiment votre
témoignage est très dur
mais on se met tous à votre place et on
se dit c'est pas possible que par un
manque de moyens parce que ça c'est
quelque chose qui aurait pu être évité
et c'est je vais vous montrer un extrait
où c'est un bébé voilà qui lui est passé
tout proche du pire parce qu'il n'a pas
pu être pris en charge rapidement et
c'est voilà c'est on aujourd'hui vous
êtes venu aussi témoigner parce que vous
voulez dire vous avez pas envie que ça
arrive à d'autres familles forcément et
c'est vrai que c'est c'est dramatique
c'est ça arrive de plus en plus voilà
c'est c'est dramatique regardez
il a quoi
il est pas bien il a quel âge bébé
elle ne le sait pas encore mais l'état
de son bébé va s'aggraver le lendemain
en fin de journée
[Musique]
la maman du bébé a parcouru en urgence
40 km pour venir jusqu'ici
c'était la même chose que je fais
depuis 2 jours comme ça
impossible de savoir précisément dans
quel état de santé se trouvait hier le
bébé
mais aujourd'hui il est en insuffisance
respiratoire
dans la nuit son état va s'aggraver
après une semaine en réanimation les
nouvelles sont bonnes
[Applaudissements]
c'est vrai que voilà quand on voit ça et
on pense forcément à vous comme nous
l'avez dit vous avez vu un terme un
dernier tel matin il fait le soir
je sais que vous avez vous avez vous
avez porté plainte oui contre qui alors
pour l'instant c'est il y a une enquête
en cours donc c'est contre X
on attend la fin de cette enquête pour
savoir est-ce que vous êtes persuadé et
vous êtes infirmière donc vous
connaissez un petit peu le voilà
certains cas vous dites que s'il était
resté à l'hôpital il aurait pu s'en
sortir
autant de temps pour un bébé 7 mois
dès le mardi soir
d'attendre le jeudi ou c'est vrai que
sur un sur un bébé de 7 mois et en plus
ça se dégrade très très vite et le temps
48 heures c'est énorme pour un petit
organisme comme ça donc forcément c'est
vrai que est-ce que je sais que vous
n'en voulez pas du tout à cette à cette
interne c'est ce que vous dites parce
que il était là le matin il était le
soir il est tellement il était il est
débordé c'est ça oui c'est ça bah puis
on a vu qu'il était fatigué puis bah on
était dans le métier en plus j'ai
conscience que c'est compliqué que en
plus de ça il y a plein de personnes qui
vont aux urgences
et qui n'ont rien à y faire en fait
c'est ça aussi et voilà c'est un tout et
du coup oui on sait qu'il était débordé
on sait que que avec la fatigue voilà
c'est enfin comment dire on peut
l'entendre enfin on en veut en fait
bien plus hautes
se dégrader comme ça
je trouve qu'on pense plus à l'argent
que en fait il y a des vies humaines
et on pense trop l'argent
de personnel que il y a des hôpitaux
aussi qui se tournent vers l'intérim et
vers tout ce qu'ils peuvent regarder
dans le dans ce reportage on est ils ont
essayé de voir les journalistes de son
interdites avec une bonne intérim s'il
pouvait eux-mêmes travailler dans un
hôpital sans diplôme regardez pour
occuper le poste il faut normalement un
an d'études et un diplôme
je n'ai pas fait votre école maternelle
non non pas encore
très bien en fin de disponibilité pour
vous ce sera à partir de ça moi je suis
disponible tout de suite vous avez bien
entendu nous n'avons pas de diplôme
d'aide-soignant et pourtant cela ne pose
aucun problème pour aller travailler
dans cet hôpital voici le contrat de
travail que nous allons recevoir
nous sommes officiellement embauchés
comme auxiliaire de vie sociale au SMIC
là encore pour exercer il faut
normalement une formation d'au moins un
an ce n'est pas notre cas
alors ça c'est incroyable et alors les
journalistes de Nathalie va donc
travailler et ce qui est fou c'est qu'on
lui donne des tâches qu'elle ne devrait
jamais faire comme donner des
médicaments regardez
deux jours plus tard notre journaliste
intègre un
service plombe donc
on savait des patients officiellement
nous sommes censés servir les repas et
faire la toilette des patients rien de
plus pendant deux jours nous serons
formés par Jessica qui a notre grand
étonnement n'est pas diplômé non plus
sur les trois personnes présentes dans
le service une seule à un diplôme de
soignants et nous allons faire une
découverte aurissante
donner des médicaments est une mission
réservée aux infirmiers car la moindre
erreur peut avoir de graves conséquences
qui vous étonne ça je suis infirmière
non moi je distribue les
personnes sont diplôme comme ça qui
travaillent à vos côtés
aujourd'hui vous en êtes où
tous les deux aujourd'hui on a eu la
chance d'avoir deux petites filles qui
nous aident beaucoup à avancer
alors Inès à trois ans et Mila a dit moi
11 mois
du tout
à avancer et de toute façon nous on est
toujours en vie donc
on a pas le choix faut continuer
cauchemardesque on se met tous à votre
place on revoit on imagine tous la scène
quand vous attendiez le
SAMU au bord de la route et c'est vrai
qu'on se dit c'est c'est une scène de
cauchemars